Mais que se passe t'il ?
Vous ne rêvez pas du tout, c'est vraiment un setup live que j'utilise pour faire une vidéo sur ma chaîne Youtube !
Mais pourquoi ?
Eh bah parce que mon studio est actuellement en travaux !(ralentissement)
*bruit de perceuse* Écoutez moi bien!!!
Dans l'année vous savez combien de fois..........les voisins ont percé un truc??
ZERO. *rire* Ça m'a pas manqué de tourner chez moi.
Du coup aujourd'hui nouveau format, cette année j'ai envie un peu de parler de ce qui m'entoure,
De ce dans quoi je baigne euuuh toute l'année à savoir : internet, à savoir : YouTube
Pour une raison très simple, je pense que mon avis importe énormément les gens
Les gens veulent savoir... ce que je pense... vraiment
c'est sûûûûr, je sais que c'est prendre des risques mais j'pense que si ça évolue à un moment donné
C'est se faire kiffer
De plus j'ai la sainte parole,
Je ne me trompe JAMAIS *écho*
*Voix de gamin* Gné gné les pyramides c'est des aliens j'ai vu le documentaire sur YouTube
*Musique illuminati*
OK on va aborder deux sujets ensemble, asseyez vous confortablement moi je me pose au bout d'un volcan actuellement
Le premier c'est le craquage récent d'un YouTuber en plein live de David Lafarge, vous connaissez tous bien évidemment.
Une personne charmante.
David a récemment fait un live 24H, voilà comme des tas de streamers font etc...
C'est intéressant ça créé une proximité avec la communauté
Bref c'est un truc qui se fait dans le stream game.
Sauf que, douche froide, il n'y avait pas grand monde sur le live de David Lafarge
Du coup il a pensé que c'était peut être un bug de YouTube
donc il a relancé son live sauf que après l'avoir relancé
le nombre de viewers n'as pas changer
c'était approximativement vraiment le même.
Y'a alors un mec qui c'est rendu sur le Live de David Lafarge et qui lui à dit : Mec, c'est pas bugé,
c'est juste qu'il ni a personnes sur ton Live...
Ce qui en soit est vrai mais...,
ça sert à quoi de l'envoyer comme ça dans la tête du gars?
C'est horrible!
"Tu bides et je montre à tout les gens qui n'avaient pas remarqué que tu bides,
QUE TU BIDES!"
QUEL ENFER!
Du coup après avoir lu se message, David il a un peu pété un câble,
et on peu le comprend.
[David LF durant son Live] N*ke ta put*** de mère
Wallah! tout ce que j'ai à te dire frérot!
Et vraiment si je te croise gros la vie de ma mère, écoute moi bien!
écoute moi bien si je te croise, tu vas voir qui c'est David Lafarge dans la vie réelle, Wallah!
Wallah gros!
WALLAH
ÉH WALLAH!
éH wALLah!
David, personne n'a de doute on sait très bien que dans la vraie vie,
t'es un gars très sympa, très cool qui se prend pas la tête,
alors ne fait pas CROIRE QUE T'ES LE PATRON DE LA MAFIA !
En vrai on rigole mais,
pourquoi je vous montre ça ? Bon déjà parce que c'est un peu drôle,
et aussi parce que sa relève un vrai délire.
Je trouve que David il a eu un peu le chemin
"cliché" du Youtuber, dans le sens où c'est un gars normal
le succès lui tombe dessus,
il se met à exploiter L'opening de booster Pokemon dans son cas,
et il en fait encore, encore et encore sachant que sa à du succès et que ça buzz
en se posant la question : Jusqu'à quand ça va marcher?
avant que sa s'épuise.
Il faisait je sais plus combien de vidéos, c'était incroyable!
Je crois qu'il en mettait 2 par jour pendant un moment donc euh...
S'enfermer dans un format de vidéos qui marchent et pas trop oser en sortir...
Parce que dès que tu en sors les states sont nulles et sa te ni*** le moral...
ça fait mal quoi.
Bref, c'est assez triste, mais l'avantage de sa c'est que sa offre des réactions incroyable en Live
comme celle-ci
mais aussi comme celle-ci:
[David Lafarge rageant  devant Fortnite]
ET OUAIS Y A UN MEC DERRIÈRE MOI AUSSI !
n'importe qui sur Fortnite, qui est dans les trois derniers vivants,
agis comme ça !
Arrêtez ne lui jetez pas la pierre !
Bref, j'ai dis ce que j'avais à dire, je sais pas si je me suis bien exprimé, parce que j'y vais un peu en impro,
mais voila, je trouve qu'il y a un vrai au delà d'un clip un peu drôle de 20 secondes,
qui a fait plus d’audiences que son Live sur Twitter
LOL HORRIBLE
ça montre ce dont tout les Youtubers actuellement qui marchent ont peur !
La chute !
la chute des stats, la chute de l'audience!
Les gens qui ce mettent à s'en battre les testicules (pour être polie) de toi!
OH MON DIEU!
J'ai vue pas mal de gens juste rire face à sa et dire : Oh le pauvre mec!
Mais en vrai voila, c'était important de contextualiser
et de ce mettre à sa place enfaîte, faut toujours se mettre à la place des autres surtout quand ils prennent des risques.
Comme moi en faisant cette vidéo....
Voila!
ça vous a plus?
Une note sur 10 dès maintenant allez y choisissez !
Attendez !
Quel est?...
C'est une alarme?
Qu'est ce qu'il ce passe là ?!
Non!
non...
NON!
Le 3ème Youtuber de France!
Dévoile son salaire en vidéo ?!
Et nan ! c'est juste du gros clique bait ! comme d'hab!
Arretez! on y à tous cru je sais,
On voulait y croire, on voulait que ça arrive, mais non...
En revanche !
Vous avez toujours rêvé de mener un business bien juteux,
et de devenir riche?
Tibo vous dit tout !
y compris les plus grand secrets de son entreprise et de son business !
Regardons ça ensemble !
[extrait d'une video de TiboInshape] Aussi surprenant que ça puisse paraître,
Youtuber aujourd'hui, c'est considéré comme un vrai métier.
ça fait au moins 3 ans que c'est le CAAAAAS!
çe qui veut dire qu'il faut se déclarer au yeux de l'Etat,
avoir sa propre société et déclarer tous les revenus qu'on gagne aux impôts.
Si jamais même quand Youtuber n'était pas vu comme un vrai métier,
Il fallait quand même...
fallait quand même faire ça en fait
Quand tu gagnes de l'argent, que ton métier soit reconnu ou pas,
il faut une structure pour l'encaisser,
une stucture qui du coup permet à l'Etat de prendre sa part
Voila, c'est comme ça !
Que l'opinion générale considère que ce que tu fais est un vrai métier ou non,
on sens "Fiche" ça n'a rien à voir...
Personnellement je gagne ma vie de 5 manières différentes,
Les revenues Youtube,
les revenue de mon sponsor de complément alimentaire: My Protein,
les droits d'auteur liés à mes vidéos,
les placements de produits dans mes vidéos qui sont plus ou moins nombreux,
et dernier point: les revenues de ma marque de vêtement.
Dans cette vidéo nous allons donc essentiellement nous consacrer sur ma marque de vêtements: TeamShape
Il y en a pour tout le monde!
Petits,
petites,
ados,  [et non pas "abdos"...rigolez svp]
et enfants.
Et adultes au corps d'enfant?...
...
Il y a des T-shirts,
des pulls, des débardeurs,
des joggings, des shorts,
des stringeurs, des polos, des shorts...
Bon Tibo c'est une vidéo sur ta boutique ou sur combien tu gagnes d'argent la?
Des leggings et des brassières.
Il y a aussi des accessoires comme:
Des stickeurs, des coques Iphones
Des tabliers...
des mugs, des shakers, des bracelets, des sacs, des serviettes, des drapeaux
des livres, des casquettes
DES CANAPÉS,
DES BOUGIES,
DES LEDS,
DES SERF-VOLANTS,
DES CHAUSSES-PIEDS!
COMBIEN TU GAGNES TIBO?!
pardon on est qu'a 3min sur 11,
ça va arriver, calmons nous, ne perdons pas patience.
il va le dire à la fin, comme sa il aura un bon watch time,
et sa video elle sera très mise en avant par Youtube du coup.
Un vrai patron d'entreprise!
Après forcement les produits que je dédicaces sont un petit peu plus chères,
car je passe une partie de ma journée à les signer 1 pars 1 personnellement...
Attendez!
On peu acheter une BD...
Dédicacée?
Qui coûte plus chère qu'une BD non dédicacée?
Il est question de sa?
La signature de Tibo vaut 2euros?!
Attendez! je viens d'avoir une idée de bisness la!
Découvrez tout les objets du quotidiens,
mugs,
chaussures,
jeans,
dédicacés par Squeezie,
Au même prix que les objets du quotidiens,
mugs,
jeans,
chaussures
mais pour 2euros de plus
Passez les commandes vite!
Mec! c'est limite...
normalement le truc de la dédicace sa ce fait
gratuitement enfaîte, c'est un effort que le créateur fait,
pour faire kiffer ces fans mais monétiser sa signature!
je trouve sa un peu limite dans se cas la,
par contre c'est archi rentable!
Sur mon site on retrouve aussi les vidéos personnalisées,
où pour 36 euros je dis tout ce que vous voulez en 15 secondes.
Là je trouve que c'est un..., moralement
on est sur un truc extra limite quand même
c'est à dire, faire des vidéos dédicaces que tu payes 36 euros!
et qui serons destiné pour la plus part à des mineurs, je veux dire c'est surtout les jeunes qui sont attirés par ce genre de truc,
les gens un peu plus vieux ils vont plus vouloir voir un spectacle,
un concert, un truc un peu plus
entertainant, si je puis dire
que juste une vidéo de 15 secondes où tu dis...
Bah regardez! y a un exemple sur le site:
DAAMN David!
C'est Tibo Inshape, juste une petite vidéo pour te dire que c'est toi qui est le meilleur!
Bon courage dans ta perte de poids on pense fort à toi !
t'as le soutien énorme et sec de toute la Team Shape,
et n'oublies pas que c'est toi qui est le meilleur,
alors les kilos en trop tu les exploses!
BOOM David!
Matisse, toi tu iras loin toi!
Toi t'es le boss! t'es le boss "donne les 36 balles"
T'es le boss Matisse!
On t'aime "36 euros"
On t'aime.
Enfaite ici ce qui pose problèmes c'est pas le fait Tibo il veule gagner de l'argent,
tout le monde veut gagner de l'argent
je veux pas que les gens croient que c'est ça que je veux lui reprocher du tout!
D'ailleur je veux pas que vous croyez qu'il faut aller lui reprocher quoi que se soit ! ,
je fais pas du tout cette vidéo pour que les gens aient niquer Tibo derrière,
et qu'il se face harceler.
Ici le soucis c'est que moralement
c'est un peu limite de faire un vidéo dédicacée à des gens,
surtout quand elle coûte 36 balles mec !
Qui est le prix d'une place de concert à Bercy pour un show de 1h30 , qui a couté des centaine de milliers d'euros d'installation pour certains,
là on parle juste d'une vidéos de 15 seconde dédicace un peu vide...
Mais après dans les faits y a des gens qui sont preneurs,
y a des gens qui sont contents que sa existe et c'est sur que ça va faire des heureux.
Donc est ce qu'il faut lui en vouloir de faire sa ou pas?
ça va surtout faire de mal à personnes.
je suis mitigé.
Mais pour ce qui comme moi trouve sa un peu chère pour une vidéo de 15 secondes
Tibo a une réponde pour vous alors TAISEZ- VOUS! , FERMEZ- LA maintenant:
Et pour les personnes qui disent que 36 euros c'est trop chère et que j'aurais du les mettrent à 10 euros,
croyais moi que même si sa coûtait 10 euros,
elle trouverait quand même sa trop chère.
Bah non...
du coup non...
peut etre qu'il aurait fallu...commencer par là,
Je sais pas...
Si un jour vous créez votre bisness
et je vous le souhaite!
qu'importe le prix que vous mettrez si ce n'est pas gratuit, ce sera toujours trop chère...
Mais nan! c'est horrible cette mentalité!
au contraire, enfaîte en disant ce genre de trucs tu incites les gens à trouver sa pas normal de faire des trucs payant,
alors que si c'est normal,si c'est legite
si c'est moralement correct ect,
par exemple acheter un vêtement sur la boutique de Tibo ou d'un autre par exemple,
y'a aucun mal à sa, t'es contents tu reçois un produit custom
que ton Youtuber préféré a fait c'est cool
c'est un échange qui est cool
mais sa pose problème quand y'a une question morale derrière, comme c'est le cas de pas mal de trucs...
donc,
vous avez vue? c'était pas un grains de beauté sa , c'est un bouton qui va devenir blanc dans très peu de jours...
Vous vous posez la question depuis le début , j'ai répondue...
On passe à autre chose:
De plus sur ces 36 euros,
comme pour les rencontres abonnées...
N'ose pas!
Il faut en levez les charges...
NOON!
Les impots et la TVA.
NAAAAN!!
Cette excuse des impots!, c'est fou!
Pour justifier un prix de vente!,
ARRETEZ!
Je ne force personnes à acheter mes produits Team Shapes.
Tu n'as pas le choix!
Tu ne peux pas forcer les gens à acheter quoi que se soit!
C'est pas un acte bienveillant de ta part...
c'est normal Tibo,
NORMAL
Aujourd'hui il faut savoir que même si un Youtuber peut gagner correctement sa vie,
qu'avec les revenues Youtube
se sont des revenues incertains,
un mois vous pouvez gagner.../Squeezie : C'est vrai! / 3000 euros,
et l'autre 500
C'est moins vrai,
Tibo,
r'ajoute un zéro...
Tu ne peux pas regarder les gens dans les yeux,
et leurs dire que un mois tu peux gagner 500,
et l'autre 3000...
Quand tu fais 45 PUT*** de MILLIONS DE VUES PAR MOIS!
TU GAGNES PLUS!
ALORS répond à ton titre, [calme toi Squeezie...]
et dis nous COMBIEN TU GAGNES!!! [on la perdu...]
Enfaite y'a pas de soucis à donner des chiffres et tout, c'est même plutôt cool à but informatif,
si t'as envie de dévoiler une information qui est perso à savoir ton salaire.
mais, partager sa avec les gens c'est cool y'en a qui l'on déjà fait comme:
Aiekillu
il l'a fait il à vraiment donné les vrais chiffre ect
allez voir ces vidéos d’ailleurs si vous etes curieux sur sa.
Soit tu en parle et t'es sincère et transparent,
soit t'en parle pas et y'a pas de soucis.
mais tu peux pas faire un entre 2, tu t’appropries le mérite d'en parler d’être transparent contrairement aux autres,
sauf qu'en réalité tu leurs met un énorme Bull shirt à la gueule.
Tibo,
je suis moi aussi Youtuber..., je fais moi aussi beaucoup de vues,
et je sais que on gagne bien plus que sa chaque mois... ;)
je le dis!
Tu ne peux pas mentir au gens comme sa , non!
sans compter les revenues de tes quatres autres
Bisness!
- Sans parler du nombres de vidéos que les Youtubers se font démonétiser chaques jours.
ÇAAAAA
c'est vrai ;)
je me suis moi aussi fait démonétiser pas mal de vidéos
mais sa a pas... pour être transparent avec vous,
sa à carrément pas changé mes revenues Youtube
parce que c'était essentiellement des vieilles vidéos,
et du coup elles font très peu de vue chaque mois
donc même si elles ne me génère pas d'argent, sa fait pas un gap immense entre le avant ou le après.
Mais peu être que Tibo c'est fait démonétiser des vidéos très récentes
au quel cas c'est vrai, ça change vraiment se que tu peux toucher.
Tous ça pour dire que ce soit en France ou ailleurs,
dès qu'on affiche, qu'on gagne de l'argent,
en faisant quelque chose qu'on aime
c'est mal vue, mais si vous travaillez dur
et que vous gagnez de l'argent de façon honnête,
alors n’ayez pas peur de votre succès .
Personnellement je n'ai pas honte de dire: que je vie de ma passion.
et si je fais cette vidéo,
c'est pour voue aider et vous donner les clés pour que vous réussissiez vous aussi à faire la même chose que moi.
C'est pour sa que je vous motive à faire du sport...
BREF!
Bullshitage terminer!
mon t shirt TeamShape est commandé.
Blague à part!
je n'est rien de personnel contre Tibo du tout!
ni contre David, ni contre quiconque donc je parlerai sur cette chaine Youtube,
c'est juste que je pense qu'il est temps en 2019
après je sais pas combien d'année de Youtube
qu'on soit tous sincère avec les gens, qu'on soit honnête avec les gens,
qu'on face des vrai discours...
Voila! c'est pas du tout dans une démarche malveillante que j'ai fais cette vidéo
qui parle de Tibo et de David,
je trouve que c'était deux actus intéressement  à décrypter
comme ça dans cette vidéo et dans parler,en plus j'ai...
TAPÉ DES BONNES BARRES!
je dois l'admettre
Bref, bonne continuation au Youtubers qui ont regardaient cette vidéo
Attention de ne pas tomber dans les pièges de Youtube
Soyez sincère, ayez des discours honnêtes moi le premier
je m'engage aussi,
voilà je veux pas être moralisateur ou quoi que se soit, mais je trouve ça intéressent de parler de trucs comme ça
surtout quand y a un vrai background, un vrai contexte
vous me direz si sa vous à plus
si c'est le cas n’hésiter pas à me le dire dans les commentaires